ah
[Música]
si no se convirtió en 2018 en el primer
país en américa latina en implementar
una legislación que prohíbe el uso de
bolsas plásticas fue todo un cambio
cultural en su momento que supuso que
las personas tuvieran que acudir a las
grandes superficies y supermercados
llevando sus propias bolsas de plástico
a partir de agosto de 2020 entró en
vigor la segunda parte de esta
legislación que afecta a las pequeñas y
medianas empresas que ya no pueden
entregar tampoco en ninguna bolsa
plástica y que sea acatado con menor
rigurosidad que sí que se hizo en la
primera parte de esta legislación que
según las autoridades ha ahorrado más de
cinco mil millones de bolsas plásticas a
chile' el congreso chileno trabaja en
estos momentos en una nueva ley que
regulará los plásticos de un solo uso
para implementar que sean reutilizados y
también la forma en que se reciclan será
una legislación que puede estar entre
las más novedosas del mundo y que cuenta
también con el buen hacer de la
legislación que ya existe a nivel
mundial y también en la unión europea en
relación a el uso del plástico
[Música]
entre california y hawai se encuentra la
isla de basura sobre todo de bolsas de
plástico más grande del mundo se calcula
que mide tres veces más del tamaño de
francia se trata de un verde verdadero
vertedero acuático los expertos creen
que comenzó a formarse a partir de los
años 50 cuando se impulsó el uso de
plásticos en occidente sobre todo bolsas
de basura y especialmente en eeuu
ahora mismo hay varios proyectos en
marcha para intentar deshacer este
vertedero gigante aunque por ahora
ninguno de ellos ha realizado grandes
avances uno de los últimos fue una
empresa europea que intentó deshacer
esta isla de basura gracias a redes de
arrastre aunque realmente no logró su
cometido porque las redes se rompieron
ahora mismo se calcula que hay más de 2
mil millones de trozos de plástico que
componen esta isla que matan al año a
miles de animales marinos y que
contaminan el ecosistema
[Música]
la unión europea y do legislando
progresivamente contra la presencia del
plástico entre los países desde este año
se prohíbe el uso de bolsas de plástico
en los supermercados sólo se utilizan
las compostables porque casi 13 millones
de toneladas acaban en el mar
mediterráneo también desde este mes de
julio no se permiten el uso de plásticos
de un solo uso como vasos también
cubiertos o platos o bastoncillos para
los oídos todo para concienciar a la
población de lo nocivo de este material
que tarda años en degradarse y que
apenas puede reciclarse de hecho algo
tan común como las botellas de plástico
de agua tendrán que tener a partir de
ahora al menos un 25% de material
reciclado con todas estas medidas la
comisión europea calcula que se podrán
reducir 4 millones de toneladas de
dióxido de carbono que se envían a la
atmósfera
[Música]